OK, before you can understand how Bob's sister became the talk of the third grade and the big day that led to that people still remember, I need to explain first that Bob's sister is a drawing. The teacher in this third grade class, Mr. Ablao, spotted it one day while teaching math. He saw one of the students, Antonio, working on a picture.
好的，在你们了解鲍勃的妹妹是如何成为三年级学生热议的话题，以及那个让他们至今难忘的重大日子之前，我首先需要解释的是，鲍勃的妹妹其实是一幅画。三年级班主任阿布劳先生在某天教数学时发现了它。他看到一名学生安东尼奥正在画画。
I went over to him and said put the picture away. I probably did that two or three times. And then the fourth time I went over, and I just took the picture and said, pay attention. It's math class.
我走过去对他说把画收起来。我大概说了两三次。第四次我走过去时，直接把画拿走说，专心点。现在是数学课。
And I put it on my desk. He came up right before recess and was like, can I have my picture back? And I was like, what is this picture of anyways? And he said, it's Bob's sister. And I'm like, who's Bob's sister? Turns out Bob's sister is a minion, which I don't even think Bob's sister exists in the minion world.
我把它放在了我的办公桌上。课间休息前他跑过来问，我能拿回我的画吗？我问，这画到底是什么？他说，是鲍勃的妹妹。我说，鲍勃的妹妹是谁？原来鲍勃的妹妹是一个小黄人，而我认为小黄人的世界里根本就没有鲍勃的妹妹。
You're saying the minions like from the movie, Despicable Me?
你是说像电影《卑鄙的我》里那样的小黄人吗？
Yes, exactly.
是的，没错。
And he had just invented like a sister character for Bob?
他只是给鲍勃编了一个妹妹的角色？
Yeah, apparently.
对，显然是这样。
Mr. Ablao taped the drawing to the bookshelf behind his desk near a photo of a wolf that was already there. Because it was clear if Antonio kept the drawing, it would continue to be a distraction to him and a couple of his friends, who, at that point, were the only ones in class who really cared about Bob's sister.
阿布劳先生把这幅画贴在了办公桌后面的书架上，旁边还有一张狼的照片。因为很明显，如果安东尼奥一直留着这幅画，它会继续分散他和几个朋友的注意力，而当时班里也只有他们几个真正关心鲍勃的妹妹。
I was like, don't worry. She's not going anywhere. She'll be right here. Anytime you want to see her, she'll be behind me.
我说，别担心。她哪儿也不会去。她就在这儿。任何时候你想见她，她都会在我身后。
Because the kids were into the picture of Bob's sister?
因为孩子们都很喜欢鲍勃的妹妹那幅画？
Yeah. And I didn't really quite understand why. I never investigated why this picture was such a big deal. But yeah, they would talk about it. They would go up and look at it. And, yeah, it was a thing.
是的。我不太明白原因。我从没去探究为什么这幅画这么重要。但他们确实会谈论它。他们会走过去看它。它确实成了个“大人物”。
Why were you guys so excited about Bob's sister, do you think?
你们觉得为什么大家会对鲍勃的妹妹这么兴奋呢？
I think it's because it was like another distraction in class that people could talk about.
我觉得是因为那是班上另一个大家可以谈论的消遣吧。
Well, that's straightforward enough.
嗯，这理由倒是够直白的。
This is Dylan, one of Antonio's friends, who was into Bob's sister from the start.
这位是迪伦，安东尼奥的朋友之一，他从一开始就对鲍勃的妹妹很感兴趣。
Describe the drawing.
描述一下那幅画。
It's just like an octopus, and then it had two eyes and then tentacles coming out of it.
它就像一只章鱼，有两只眼睛，还有触手伸出来。
I didn't realize Bob's sister was an octopus?
我没意识到鲍勃的妹妹是只章鱼？
Bob's sister was an octopus.
鲍勃的妹妹是只章鱼。
But Bob's a minion.
但鲍勃是个小黄人。
Well, it didn't really have anything to do with that.
嗯，这其实和那没什么关系。
And was he referring to the minion Bob, or am I just--
他是指小黄人鲍勃，还是我只是——
No--
不——
No.
不。
--he was not.
——他指的不是。
I see. Was it a good drawing?
我明白了。那是幅好画吗？
It was like, an eight-year-old's OK drawing. Like, it wasn't amazing, but it was like, you knew what it was.
就像一个八岁孩子画的还不错的画。不是那种惊世之作，但你一看就知道画的是什么。
This whole question-- is it an octopus, is it a minion-- I asked Antonio, who drew Bob's sister-- about that. He tended to see Bob's sister as a Pac-Man ghost with big eyes, but he said-- and I thought it was surprisingly mature for somebody in elementary school. He thought part of the appeal of Bob's sister was that it was open to interpretation.
关于这到底是一只章鱼还是一个小黄人的问题，我问过创作出鲍勃的妹妹的安东尼奥。他倾向于认为鲍勃的妹妹是一个有着大眼睛的吃豆人幽灵，但他说——我认为对于一个小学生来说这太成熟了——他认为鲍勃的妹妹之所以吸引人，是因为它有解读空间。
I really don't know what it is. It's a thing. I don't know what it-- it's lots of different things. You could think of it as a minion that looks weird. You could think of it as Fly Guy with no legs. You could think of it as Pac-Man ghost with big eyes.
我真的不知道它是什么。它就是一个东西。我不知道它——它有很多种含义。你可以认为它是一个看起来很奇怪的小黄人。你可以认为它是一个没有腿的“苍蝇小子”。你可以认为它是一个有大眼睛的吃豆人幽灵。
Bob's sister was different to everybody. We never went with one of them. We didn't say anything. Anyone could believe what they want.
鲍勃的妹妹对每个人来说都是不同的。我们从没统一过定论。我们什么都没说。每个人都可以相信他们想相信的。
But the thing that was key to Bob's sister was, Bob's sister wasn't actually anyone's sister.
但关于鲍勃的妹妹最关键的一点是，她实际上并不是任何人的妹妹。
His name was just Bobsister, no space.
它的名字就叫“鲍勃妹妹”（Bobsister），连在一起，没有空格。
That's really funny.
那真好笑。
And we didn't come up with a gender either.
而且我们也没有给它定性别。
So Bobsister, gender unspecified, lived on the bookshelf near the photo of a wolf, until one week when Mr. Ablao went on vacation, and the kids had a substitute. When Mr. Ablao came back, Bobsister was gone, vanished, disappeared, and was all the kids wanted to talk about. This is the point where everybody in class gets very, very interested in Bobsister.
于是“鲍勃妹妹”，性别不详，一直生活在狼的照片旁边的书架上，直到阿布劳先生去度假的一周，班里换了代课老师。当阿布劳先生回来时，鲍勃妹妹不见了，消失了，失踪了，而这成了孩子们唯一想谈论的话题。这时班里所有人都对鲍勃妹妹产生了浓厚兴趣。
There's kind of all this speculation about what happened to Bobsister. Was she stolen? Was she murdered? Did she die? And so I go and I look a little bit. I looked under the desk. I looked behind the bookshelf and--
大家都在猜测鲍勃妹妹发生了什么。她是被人偷走了吗？是被谋杀了吗？她死了吗？于是我去寻找了一番。我看了桌子底下。看了书架后面，还有——
Did you ask the substitute?
你问过代课老师吗？
I did, actually. He had no idea what I was talking about, which was good enough for me.
确实问过。他根本不知道我在说什么，这对我来说就足够了。
Oh, really? For me, that makes him suspect number one.
哦，真的吗？对我来说，这让他成了头号嫌疑人。
[LAUGHS] Interesting.
[笑] 有趣。
There's your guy. Do you not watch any crime drama at all?
你的嫌疑人找到了。你难道一点犯罪剧都不看吗？
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
There are all kinds of theories about what happened to Bobsister. Antonio and Dylan said it was really fun to talk about various abductors, including animals from an alternate universe. But Dylan says the prime suspect for his classmates-- that other picture on the bookshelf.
关于鲍勃妹妹身上发生了什么，有各种各样的理论。安东尼奥和迪伦说讨论各种绑架者很有趣，甚至包括来自平行宇宙的动物。但迪伦说他同学们的头号怀疑对象是书架上的那张照片。
They just decided that the wolf ate it because it was like, right above the wolf.
他们只是认定是狼把它吃了，因为它就在狼的上方。
Like the wolf was jealous or something.
就像那匹狼嫉妒了一样。
They didn't really know why. That's what they said.
他们其实不知道为什么。但他们就是这么说的。
Who said that?
谁说的？
Basically, everybody.
基本上所有人。
I mean, he's a wolf.
毕竟它是匹狼。
Yeah.
是的。
The chatter about Bobsister does not go away, which is funny, but also Mr. Ablao's got a curriculum to get through.
关于鲍勃妹妹的闲谈一直没有停止，这很滑稽，但阿布劳先生还要赶课程进度。
I'm kind of vaguely annoyed because there's a lot going on in the school day, and I don't have much time to think about a picture of Bobsister. But they're kind of pestering me about it.
我感到有点烦，因为学校每天要处理的事情很多，我没时间去想一张鲍勃妹妹的画。但他们一直在为此缠着我。
And then one other student--
然后另一个学生——
Dylan, actually.
其实是迪伦。
--pipes in and says, can we have a funeral for Bobsister? And I'm like, what are you talking about? And they're like, well, she died. Something happened.
——插话说，我们可以为鲍勃妹妹举行一场葬礼吗？我说，你在说什么呀？他们说，好吧，她死了。发生了一些事。
And I'm like, a funeral for Bobsister, a picture? And I say yes.
我说，为鲍勃妹妹，一张画，举行葬礼？我答应了。
Probably just to get them to stop talking about Bobsister, but also, this is the kind of teacher he is. He says, sometimes, it's smart to take some detours, follow things where they lead.
也许只是为了让他们停止谈论鲍勃妹妹，但同时，他也是那种老师。他说，有时绕点路，顺其自然地跟随事物发展是明智的。
And they're like, when? I'm like, I don't know when. I don't know when this funeral's going to happen. And they're like, when? When's it going to happen? When's it going to happen? We are going to have a funeral for Bobsister. And so then, finally, I'm like, after recess on Friday.
他们问，什么时候？我说，我不知道什么时候。我不知道这场葬礼什么时候举行。他们问，什么时候？什么时候举行？什么时候举行？我们要为鲍勃妹妹办一场葬礼。最后，我说，周五课间休息之后。
That was Monday. The rest of the week goes pretty normally. Mr. Ablao sort of hoped that they would forget about the funeral by the end of the week, but no way. They're murmuring about it, preparing for it, which he has no part of.
那是周一。剩下的一周过得还算正常。阿布劳先生本来希望他们到周末会忘记葬礼的事，但根本没可能。他们一直在低声议论，为它做准备，而这与他无关。
The eight-year-olds are the ones organizing this and thinking it through. Finally, Friday arrives, the big day, the day of the funeral, kids come back into the room from recess.
八岁的孩子们正在筹划这一切并进行思考。终于，周五到了，大日子，葬礼之日，孩子们课间休息后回到教室。
They're pretty giddy and pretty excited. So finally, I'm like, OK, game on, let's go. Funeral. I have no idea what is about to transpire. All of a sudden, boom, the tables kind of move out of the way.
他们非常兴奋和激动。于是最后我说，好吧，开始吧，我们去举行葬礼。我根本不知道接下来会发生什么。突然间，砰的一声，桌子被移开了。
The leader of the funeral comes up with the stool. Two other students bring two tables and grab the flowers. Apparently, a bunch of girls had been making posters. They write Bobsister's Funeral on the board.
葬礼的领导者拿着凳子走上台。另外两个学生搬来两张桌子并拿了花。显然，一群女孩一直在制作海报。他们在黑板上写下“鲍勃妹妹的葬礼”。
Dylan's the leader of the funeral, and he prepared a eulogy. So did his friend, Theo. Dylan gets in front of the class holding a microphone Mr. Ablao keeps in the room.
迪伦是葬礼的领导者，他准备了一篇悼词。他的朋友西奥也准备了一篇。迪伦拿着阿布劳先生放在教室里的麦克风站在班级前面。
The rest of the class is totally on the edge of their seats, just waiting for this kid to start the funeral, like, paying more attention to him than they had ever paid to me. They're just like, ready for it. He starts out kind of ad-libbing about welcoming everyone, thanking everyone for coming to celebrate the life of Bobsister.
班里其他人完全全神贯注，等待着这个孩子开始葬礼，好像对他比对我关注多了。他们准备好了。他开始即兴发挥，欢迎大家，感谢大家的到来，共同庆祝鲍勃妹妹的一生。
Now, how did you know what to say in a eulogy?
你是怎么知道悼词该说什么的？
We didn't. We just said like some things that sounded about right. Like, something that you might say at a funeral that might make someone cry.
我们不知道。我们只是说了一些听起来不错的话。就像你在葬礼上可能会说的，可能会让别人哭出来的话。
Do you have your eulogy there?
你有你的悼词吗？
Yeah. Take it out?
有的。拿出来吗？
Could you read it?
你能读一下吗？
OK, one sec. And then it sort of-- mine also says sort of back and forth she and he, so. Because I didn't really know. "Bobsister was a great person. People thought that Bob was just a drawing on a piece of paper, but I knew he was anything but that. But she is still in here. She made me think I could do things in school. If she was here today, she would say, keep on trying."
好的，等一下。而且内容有点……我的悼词里称呼一会儿是“她”一会儿是“他”，因为我确实不知道。“鲍勃妹妹是一个伟大的人。人们认为鲍勃只是纸上的一幅画，但我知道他不仅于此。但她仍然在这里。她让我觉得我在学校里能做成事情。如果她今天在这儿，她会说，继续努力。”
That's really nice. It sounds like you were trying to be sort of inspiring.
真好。听起来你想表现得很励志。
Yeah.
是的。
Had you seen a eulogy in a movie or something that you knew what to do?
你是在电影或其他地方看过葬礼吗，所以知道该怎么做？
Nope, never.
没，从来没看过。
Whoa.
哇。
The other eulogy that Theo wrote was also really good. "I just want to say something about the special person here, Bobsister, how she was such a good friend to all the potatoes, and especially Mr. Potato Head." Potatoes were another fascination of Mr. Ablao's class that year. "What an honor it was to have her with us. God bless her." And then, from the back of the room, Mr. Ablao hears a boy crying.
西奥写的另一篇悼词也写得很好。“我只是想对这里的一位特别的人，鲍勃妹妹说几句话，她对所有土豆，特别是土豆先生来说是多么好的朋友。”土豆是那一年阿布劳先生班上另一个着迷的事物。“能有她陪伴我们是多么荣幸。上帝保佑她。”然后，从教室后面，阿布劳先生听到一个男孩在哭。
I would say almost wailing, but it was like a real cry. And at first, I'm thinking, oh my god, now they're just turning this into a joke. And then, I realized that he's actually seriously crying. Like, this is not a joke cry.
我会说几乎是号啕大哭，但这是一种真正的哭泣。起初，我心想，天哪，现在他们只是把它变成了一个笑话。然后，我意识到他真的在认真地哭。这不是那种假哭。
And I walked back there. And everyone kind of turns back. Everyone's looking at both of us. And so I asked him. I'm like, what's wrong? What's going on? Why are you crying?
我走到后面。每个人都回过头来。大家都在看着我们俩。我问他。我说，怎么了？发生了什么？你为什么在哭？
And he's like, it's because Bobsister died. And I was like, it's not about anything else, maybe? And he's like, no, it's Bobsister's died, and it's just so sad.
他说，是因为鲍勃妹妹死了。我说，不是因为别的什么事吗？他说，没有，鲍勃妹妹死了，太难过了。
Mr. Ablao thinks maybe it was really about his dog. The dog that boy had grown up with had died just two weeks before. His mom had sent an email to let him know. But Mr. Ablao's really not sure. At eight, you're plenty old enough to catch a glimpse of what death means.
阿布劳先生心想也许这和他的狗有关。那个男孩从小一起长大的狗在两周前死了。他妈妈发邮件告诉过他。但阿布劳先生并不确定。八岁的时候，你已经足够大了，能理解死亡意味着什么。
And then I look up, and then the whole kind of feel of the classroom has changed. It's gone from kind of giddy excitement, this is a fun thing, to half the class is nervously laughing, and the other half looks like they're on the verge of tears. Like, there's about three girls that are kind of really sad.
然后我抬头看，教室里的气氛完全变了。从那种兴奋的激动感，变成了一种有趣的玩闹，变成了半个班级在紧张地笑着，另一半看起来像是快要哭出来了。大约有三个女孩真的非常难过。
And I was like, oh no, what have I created? This was reaching an emotional level that I actually had never experienced before, and I've been teaching for about 15 years. And I had never felt kind of this-- not that it was getting out of control, but it was leading to something that I didn't know how it was going to end, honestly. Like, I don't know what's going to happen next. If three other kids start crying, I don't know how to handle the situation.
心想，哦不，我创造了什么？这达到了一个我从未经历过的情感高度，而我已经教了15年书了。我从未感受到这种——并不是说它失去了控制，而是它引导向了一些我不知道如何收场的事情。说实话。我不知道接下来会发生什么。如果另外三个孩子开始哭，我不知道该怎么处理这种情况。
Right.
没错。
I had never experienced kind of that in a classroom.
我从来没在教室里经历过这种情况。
It's so interesting. It's like they were playing around with, I don't know, like with a Ouija board and joking around, and suddenly, they accidentally summoned a demon into the room.
真有趣。就像他们在玩那种，我不知道，就像拿着通灵板玩闹，结果突然不小心把恶魔召唤到了房间里。
Yeah. In a way. And for me, I was right there on the Ouija board with them.
是的。在某种程度上。对我来说，我就和他们一起在通灵板上。
And so this monster is in the room. You've unleashed this really kind of a primal force, like this grief, right?
所以这个怪物在房间里了。你释放了一种原始的力量，比如悲伤，对吧？
Yeah. Grief, death. And I mean, one of the really neat things about third grade is it's-- I mean, there's a saying. "They stop learning to read and are reading to learn." So it's like it's an age where their world gets a lot bigger. They kind of are experiencing real things, and I think a funeral is one of those things.
是的。悲伤，死亡。我想三年级最美妙的事情之一就是——有一句话叫，“他们停止为了阅读而学习，改为通过阅读来学习。”所以这是一个他们的世界变得大得多的年龄。他们在经历真实的事物，我认为葬礼就是其中之一。
They probably all heard of a funeral. They read them in books. But most of them probably hadn't been to one and didn't know what that felt like.
他们可能都听说过葬礼。他们在书中读到过。但大多数人可能没参加过，不知道那种感觉是什么样。
And Mr. Ablao felt responsible to help them through this new experience, like he had lots of others that year. So he took control of the room back from the kids and addressed them all.
阿布劳先生感到有责任帮助他们度过这种新的体验，就像那一年他帮助他们经历的其他许多事一样。于是他从孩子们手中夺回了房间的控制权，并对他们所有人讲话。
I was like, well, funerals are kind of serious. Sometimes, when you go to a funeral, it's very sad because you're missing the person that's moved on. And sometimes, it reminds you of other people who have moved on. And it's important to remember those people, and it's important to be sad. And this is the end of the funeral.
我说，嗯，葬礼是严肃的事情。有时当你参加葬礼时，这很悲伤，因为你在怀念那个离去的人。有时，它会让你想起其他离去的人。记住那些人很重要，感到悲伤也很重要。葬礼到此结束。
Which worked. Everybody snapped out of it. The demon left the room. Next, was free time, which they all enjoy. And everything was fine.
这奏效了。每个人都从情绪中走出来了。恶魔离开了房间。接下来是自由时间，他们都很喜欢。一切都恢复了正常。
But at the end of the school year, when the class stood in a circle and each kid names something that they remembered and liked from third grade, a couple of the kids said Bobsister's funeral. It was a moment for Mr. Ablao, too.
但在学年末，当全班围成一圈，每个孩子说出他们记得并喜欢的三年级趣事时，有几个孩子说了“鲍勃妹妹的葬礼”。这也是阿布劳先生的一个重要时刻。
Sometimes, you're joking around and it's all light and fun and trying something you've never done before, and some bigger subterranean force gets unleashed. That's what our show is going to be about today-- those moments when you get a glimpse of all that feeling that's there down below, hidden from sight. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
有时，你在开玩笑，一切都很轻松有趣，尝试一些你从未做过的事情，而一些更大的潜意识力量就被释放了。这就是我们今天要谈论的主题——那些让你瞥见隐藏在视线之下、内心深处所有感受的时刻。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Music of the Night After Night After Night After Night After Night After Night After Night After Night-- [FADES AWAY]
第一幕，夜后的夜后的夜后的夜后的夜后的夜后的音乐—— [声音渐隐]
So when you go to a big theater, you see all the people who are on stage-- they're brightly lit. They're visible to everybody. They are literally there to be seen.
当你走进一个大剧院，你会看到舞台上所有的人——他们灯火通明。每个人都能看见他们。他们确实是为了被看见而存在。
But then, just below them down in front, there's the orchestra pit. And it seems straightforward enough what happens in there. Musicians play their instruments.
但就在他们前面下方，有乐池。在那里发生的事情似乎相当直接。音乐家们演奏他们的乐器。
But other things go on in there, all kinds of interactions and feelings that usually we don't get much of a picture of. You know the old saying "hell is other people?" It actually comes from the theater, it comes from a play, No Exit.
但在那里还发生着其他事情，各种通常我们不太了解的互动和感受。你知道那句老话“他人即地狱”吗？它实际上源于戏剧，源于一部叫《禁闭》的剧。
That play was not written by somebody who sits in the orchestra pit. But Jay Caspian Kang has this story about how many musicians in theatrical orchestras might understand the sentiment. We first broadcast this story back in 2020. We are bringing it back today with an update. Here's Jay.
那部剧不是坐在乐池里的人写的。但杰伊·卡斯皮安·康有个故事，关于剧院乐团的许多音乐家可能如何理解这种情感。我们在2020年首次播出了这个故事。今天我们带着更新的版本把它带回来。这是杰伊。
Nick Jemo moved to New York in 2006 to try to make it as a musician. He had just finished up college and had all these dreams of playing the trumpet for a living, but it was a struggle. There just aren't many jobs for trumpet players anymore. So he mostly waited by the phone for gigs.
尼克·杰莫于2006年搬到纽约，试图成为一名音乐家。他刚大学毕业，怀揣着靠吹小号为生的梦想，但这很挣扎。现在小号手的就业岗位不多了。所以他大部分时间都在电话旁等待演出。
Korean megachurch services, experimental plays, and the occasional substitute job with Mary Poppins on Broadway. And then a spot opened up at his favorite show.
韩国大型教会礼拜、实验性戏剧，偶尔在百老汇演出《欢乐满人间》的替补工作。然后他最喜欢的节目出现了一个空缺。
This might be TMI, but I remember I was in my apartment. I was on the toilet. And [CHUCKLING] I got a phone call, and I didn't recognize the number. And I listened to the voicemail saying, "Hi, this is Kristen," and freaked out.
这可能是太多信息了，但我记得我当时在公寓里。我在厕所里。然后[笑]我接到了一个电话，我不认识那个号码。我听了语音留言说，“你好，我是克里斯汀，”然后我惊呆了。
This is one of the conductors for Phantom of the Opera. She offered him a job playing shows six days a week and twice on Thursdays and Saturdays.
她是《歌剧魅影》的指挥之一。她给了他一份每周演出六次，周四和周六演出两次的工作。
I'm not sure I probably even let her finish her sentence. Yes, I'm very interested, very interested and available. It was life changing, really.
我不确定我是否让她把话说完了。是的，我非常感兴趣，非常有兴趣并且有档期。这确实改变了生活。
Did you feel like you'd won the lottery?
你觉得你中了大奖吗？
Oh, yes. Actually, I remember the next day, I had to go grocery shopping. And I remember buying coconut water. I don't know why. That was like my treat because I always wanted to buy coconut water, but it was always like too much of a-- I was like, you know what? I just don't need to spend. And I remember buying coconut water and feeling like such a bad ass.
噢，是的。其实，我记得第二天，我得去买杂货。我记得我买了椰子水。我不知道为什么。那是我的奖励，因为我一直想买椰子水，但总是觉得有点……我当时心想，你知道吗？我不需要太省。我记得我买椰子水时感觉自己像个硬汉。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I just felt like, I can buy anything here.
我感觉，我可以买下这里的任何东西。
It wasn't just a steady income Nick was excited about. Phantom of the Opera was a show Nick had loved since he was 11 years old. He had just started playing the trumpet and would lay on his living room floor listening to "The Music of the Night." You know it-- (SINGING) slowly, gently, night unfurls its splendor.
尼克兴奋的不仅是稳定的收入。《歌剧魅影》是他从11岁起就喜欢的剧。他刚开始学吹小号时，会躺在客厅的地板上听《夜之音乐》。你知道的——（演唱）缓慢地、轻柔地，夜展开了它的辉煌。
That call changed his life. He had finally arrived, Phantom on Broadway. On his first day, Nick entered the Majestic Theater on 46th and 8th Avenue. He walked through a back alley past a giant tub of dry ice, down a flight of stairs into a locker room where he changed into all black.
那个电话改变了他的一生。他终于抵达了，百老汇的《魅影》。第一天，尼克进入了第46街和第八大道的雄伟剧院。他穿过一条后巷，经过一个巨大的干冰桶，顺着楼梯走进更衣室，换上了一身黑色的衣服。
He then headed into the pit to play the music he had loved as a child. He had his own seat there now and a music stand. So he played the first show. Next day, he went back and played it again and then again.
然后他进入乐池，演奏他儿时喜爱的音乐。他现在有了自己的座位和乐谱架。所以他演出了第一场。第二天，他又回去演了一次，然后又是下一次。
His brain started to adjust to playing the same show eight times a week. And then he started to notice, it wasn't just the music that repeated itself.
他的大脑开始适应每周演八次同样的节目。然后他开始注意到，重复的不仅是音乐。
I'm seeing the same actors at the exact same time and the same musicians at the exact same time and seeing the same people in the bathroom at the exact same time.
我在完全相同的时间看到同样的演员，在完全相同的时间看到同样的音乐家，在完全相同的时间在洗手间看到同样的人。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Every time one of the dancers comes through to put her wig on, she says to one of the other dancers, "Good job, Erica." Like every single day. It's very Groundhog Day.
每次其中一个舞蹈演员走过来戴上假发时，她都会对另一个舞蹈演员说，“干得好，埃里卡。”就像每一天都一样。这很“土拨鼠日”。
At first, this is funny, almost charming. Nick was 30 and the youngest person in the pit, not by a few years, but by a few decades. He'd never been in a situation like this where everyone seemed so locked into routine.
起初，这很有趣，甚至有些迷人。尼克30岁，是乐池里最年轻的人，不是小几岁，而是小了几十年。他从未经历过这种每个人似乎都锁在常规里的情况。
His colleagues would sit down in their chairs at the exact same minute every day. There is a cellist who would say, "Marvelous," every time Nick asked him how he was doing. There was the first horn player who would pull out a stopwatch every single night to time how long the second horn player held a note in one of the songs. Some days it would be 17 seconds, other days 16.2.
他的同事们每天都会在同一分钟坐到椅子上。有一位大提琴手，每次尼克问他过得怎么样，他都会说“太棒了”。有一位第一圆号手，每天晚上都会拿出秒表给第二圆号手在某首歌里长音持续的时间计时。有时是17秒，有时是16.2秒。
You definitely start to notice, people are talking about each other and complaining about the same people are late every single week. If you bump into a stand by accident, you'll get like a "what the [MUTED] are you doing," kind of look? Like, [INHALES] take a deep breath. Like, [EXHALES]
你绝对会开始注意到，人们在谈论彼此，抱怨同样的人每周都迟到。如果你不小心撞到谱架，你会得到一种“你到底在干什么[消音]”的眼神？就像，[吸气]深呼吸。就像，[呼气]
What is it like being the youngest guy there, the young guy?
作为那里最年轻的人，年轻人，是什么感觉？
Basically, I'm not as jaded as the rest of them. If I say anything that's not like, [SIGHS] "it sucks to be here," they're like, "You haven't been here long enough. You're still new. You're still new." People kind of walk in there, like, [SIGHS], OK, I got to do this again. And some of it is just in their body language, the way they walk in the door. Like they're kind of trudging in. Or when someone says, "Do I have to do this tonight?"
基本上，我没有他们那么疲惫。如果我说任何不像是[叹气]“待在这儿真糟糕”的话，他们就会说，“你待的时间还不够长。你还是个新手。你还是个新手。”人们走进去时就像[叹气]，好吧，我又得干这个了。有些就体现在他们的肢体语言上，他们走进门的方式。就像他们正拖着步子走进来。或者当有人说，“我今晚非得这么做吗？”
Phantom of the Opera opened on Broadway in January 1988. It was an instant hit.
《歌剧魅影》于1988年1月在百老汇首演。它立刻大获成功。
Everyone who has seen this musical comes away enchanted.
每一个看过这部音乐剧的人都沉醉其中。
The show is virtually guaranteed to run well into the next decade.
该剧几乎肯定会运行到下一个十年。
It did. And then another decade, and another. The musicians in the pit signed contracts with the provision, which guaranteed their jobs until the show shut down. They expected two, maybe three years.
确实如此。然后又一个十年，又一个。乐池里的音乐家们签了合同，合同中有一个条款，保证在演出结束前他们都有工作。他们预计会持续两三年。
But the show kept going, as three years turned into five years, which then turned into 32. That's over 13,000 performances. Phantom is now the longest-running show in the history of Broadway.
但演出继续进行，三年变成了五年，然后变成了32年。那是超过13,000场演出。《魅影》现在是百老汇历史上演出时间最长的剧目。
There's almost a feeling, I think, of nausea, that you have to do it again, and you have to do it again.
我想，甚至有一种恶心的感觉，你必须再次去做，你必须再次去做。
That's Melanie Feld, an oboist who's been in the pit for 28 years now.
那是梅兰妮·费尔德，一位在乐池待了28年的双簧管演奏家。
I don't know how to describe it-- a physical sensation that I get of, literally, that I'm jumping out of my skin. Like, it's a leg thing. I can't stand my skin. I'm going crazy. Oh, no, that thing is happening.
我不知道怎么形容——我有一种身体上的感觉，字面上就是，我想跳出自己的皮肤。这是一种腿部的问题。我受不了自己的皮肤。我要疯了。噢，不，那种感觉又要来了。
I had first heard about the pit at Phantom through a friend, whose wife had recently subbed in the violin section. She described what she had seen as a horror show, like Waiting for Guffman, but 30 hard years down the line. I couldn't quite get it out of my head.
我第一次听说《魅影》乐池是通过一个朋友，他的妻子最近在小提琴组担任替补。她形容她看到的简直是恐怖片，就像《等待古夫曼》，但却是30年后的残酷现实。我无法把这个念头赶出脑海。
So one of the first things people ask-- how can you possibly stay sane and play the same music every night?
所以人们问的第一件事就是——你怎么可能保持清醒，并且每天晚上演奏同样的音乐？
Pete Reit has been playing Phantom since opening night. He's the French horn player who times the notes on a stopwatch every night.
皮特·雷特从首演之夜起就一直在演奏《魅影》。他就是那个每晚用秒表给长音计时的法国号手。
Now, there is something in that, where you-- I would look at the music sometimes, and it would just literally look like shapes. I would just see, like, circles and lines and dots. And I would have no idea. I wouldn't even know what page I was on.
现在，其中确实有那么一种状态，你——我有时看着乐谱，它看起来就像一些形状。我只会看到，比如，圆圈、线条和点。我根本不知道我在哪。我甚至不知道我在哪一页。
It's like a dissociative feeling, almost. Like--
这几乎像是一种解离的感觉。就像——
It's sort of like hearing yourself speak, and you don't-- and you aren't sure it's English.
这有点像听见自己说话，而你——而你不确定那是不是英语。
(LAUGHING) OK, well, that is-- I don't think that's ever happened to me, Pete.
（大笑）好吧，嗯，那是——我觉得我从来没发生过那样的事，皮特。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And then, the funny thing is, you see someone else do it, and you immediately know what's going on with them.
然后，有趣的事情是，你看到别人也那样，你就立刻知道他们发生了什么。
What does their face look like?
他们的脸看起来是什么样的？
Oh, they're just like-- it's as if they don't even know where they are. They're, like, waking up in another room. It's like, what happened? Where am I? (LAUGHING) What day is it? What week is it?
噢，他们只是——就好像他们甚至不知道自己在哪里。他们就像在另一个房间醒来。就像，发生了什么？我在哪？（大笑）今天星期几？现在是哪一周？
When I started talking to the pit musicians a couple of years ago, I wanted to know how they found meaning in the mundane and inevitable repetitions of life. In lots of jobs, people do the same thing every day, but nothing quite like this. You're hearing the exact same lines from the stage, playing the exact same notes for the same songs.
当我几年前开始和乐池音乐家交谈时，我想知道他们如何在平庸和不可避免的生活重复中找到意义。在许多工作中，人们每天都在做同样的事情，但没有哪种像这样。你听着舞台上完全相同的台词，为同样的歌曲演奏完全相同的音符。
Even the guy sitting next to you breathes in the exact same rhythm. Every day, the Phantom kisses Christine for the first time, and the same chandelier comes crashing down in the same spot on the stage.
甚至坐在你旁边的人呼吸的节奏都完全一样。每天，“魅影”第一次亲吻克里斯汀，同样的吊灯会在舞台上同一个点坠落。
I assumed the orchestra members were like zen archers, who pull back the same bow, with the same motion, until they die. I talked to a trumpet player named Lowell Hershey. Lowell has been at the show since day one, and everyone says he's the sanest person in the pit.
我以为管弦乐队成员就像禅宗弓箭手，以同样的动作拉开同样的弓，直到他们死去。我和一位叫洛厄尔·赫尔希的小号手谈过。洛厄尔从第一天起就在这个剧组，每个人都说他是乐池里最清醒的人。
And it kind of drives you nuts for the first few weeks, and then after that, your mind deals with it and just flushes it out. So when you're not there, you don't think about it.
前几周这确实会让人抓狂，然后在那之后，你的大脑就会处理它并把它排出去。所以当你不在那儿的时候，你根本不会去想它。
Do you know the words to the songs that you're playing?
你知道你演奏的歌曲的歌词吗？
Uh, no. (CHUCKLING) Not entirely.
呃，不。（轻笑）不完全知道。
"Where in the world--"
“身处何方——”
"--think of me fondly." Whatever. I mean, I remember one time, after the show had been running for a while, somebody asked me to play a little bit of a tune from the show, and I couldn't even do it. I couldn't even think of one. (LAUGHING) I had submerged it so much.
“——深情地想我。”随它吧。我的意思是，我记得有一次，在演出运行一段时间后，有人让我演奏一点剧里的曲子，我甚至做不到。我甚至想不起一段。（大笑）我已经把它掩埋得太深了。
I feel like your brain has, basically, just rejected being cognizant that the music is going on.
我觉得你的大脑基本上已经拒绝意识到音乐正在进行。
I think that's typical of people who do shows.
我认为这是做演出的典型反应。
What do you think the right type of personality is, that can handle this job?
你认为什么样的人格类型能胜任这份工作？
I'm descended from a long line of serfs and peons, you know, people who are used to laboring in the fields for hardly any money and are relatively happy with that.
我是农奴和苦工的后代，你知道，那些习惯了在田间耕作却几乎赚不到钱，而且对此相对满足的人。
The Phantom players aren't exactly serfs. They're well-paid, they play a beloved show, and they get to play in small orchestras on the side. But these are highly trained musicians who went to the fanciest music schools in the world.
《魅影》的演奏者们并不完全是农奴。他们报酬丰厚，演奏着深受喜爱的剧目，而且还能在副业的小管弦乐队中演奏。但这些人是受过高度训练的音乐家，毕业于世界上最顶尖的音乐学校。
Andrew Lloyd Webber wanted the best of the best for Phantom, which means the pit will always sound good, though it also creates some creative and spiritual problems for the players, who have to get through the score night after night after night.
安德鲁·劳埃德·韦伯想为《魅影》寻找最棒的人，这意味着乐池听起来总是很棒，尽管这也给演奏者带来了一些创造性和精神上的困扰，他们必须日复一日地熬过这些乐谱。
I'm a violin operator.
我是一名小提琴操作员。
[LAUGHS] Is that how you describe that?
[笑] 你是这么形容它的吗？
That's how I describe it, yeah. You know, it's very technical. I have-- I have no emotional connection with it.
我是这么形容它的，是的。你知道，这非常技术性。我与它没有任何情感联系。
That's a violinist, named Kurt Coble. He's a composer. His dream was always to write scores for horror films. He's now been at Phantom for 22 years, long enough to see three people in his section die.
那是小提琴手，叫库尔特·科布尔。他是一位作曲家。他的梦想一直为恐怖电影写乐谱。他现在已经在《魅影》待了22年，久到足以目睹他组里的三个人去世。
When I'm playing the show, nobody's interested in my creative input. I've often compared it to working in a hospice. It's just-- we just keep the show alive as long as we can.
当我演奏这部剧时，没人对我的创造性投入感兴趣。我经常把它比作在临终关怀医院工作。这就是——我们只是尽可能地让剧活下去。
So here they all are, in this weird social experiment, trapped together for decades, 27 musicians crammed into this tiny space. A trumpet player told me it's like playing in a submarine. I've been down there, and you can barely turn around without knocking into something.
所以他们都聚在这里，在这个奇怪的社会实验中，被困在一起几十年，27名音乐家挤在这个狭小的空间里。一位小号手告诉我，这就像在潜艇里演奏。我下去过，你不碰到什么东西几乎无法转过身。
In the pit, you notice everything. The way your neighbor blows out a spit valve, the way someone brags about their kids, the smell of someone's perfume-- every little annoyance, every perceived slight, accumulates.
在乐池里，你会注意到一切。邻居吐口水阀的方式、某人吹嘘孩子的方式、某人香水的味道——每一个小烦恼，每一个被感知的怠慢，都在累积。
One of my favorite stories, which would drive anyone who has ever played in a band crazy-- there's this bassoon player who has sat next to the same clarinet player since 1988. She's convinced he plays half a note flat on every note he's ever played. He denies this.
我最喜欢的故事之一，会让任何在乐队里演奏过的人抓狂——有位巴松管手自1988年起就一直坐在同一位单簧管手旁边。她坚信他演奏的每一个音符都低了半个音。他否认这一点。
The person I talked to the most in the pit was Melanie, the oboist. She's one of the rare people you meet who has no real filter.
我在乐池里谈话最多的是梅兰妮，那位双簧管演奏家。她是那种你遇到的几乎没有滤镜的罕见的人。
So I was complaining about something which I imagine was that it was really cold. It's always really cold. And then, someone else from the orchestra said-- [SIGHS] I'm just so tired of the sound of your voice.
我当时在抱怨某件事，我想是因为那里真的很冷。那里总是很冷。然后，管弦乐队的另一个人说——[叹气]我真是太厌倦听你的声音了。
You know? And I'm tired of the sound of my voice, too, so I kind of sympathize with her. Then, there was a violinist who got mad at me because I said I use Roundup in my garden. She's like-- [HUFFS] And she wouldn't speak to me for, I don't know, weeks.
你知道吗？我也厌倦了听我自己的声音，所以我有点同情她。然后，有一位小提琴手因为我说我在花园里用农达除草剂而对我生气。她说——[哼]然后好几周不跟我说话。
During most of our talks, Melanie was making reeds. It's an extraordinarily meticulous process. There's all sorts of medieval-looking tools and tiny bits of wood everywhere.
在我们大部分谈话中，梅兰妮都在做哨片。这是一个极其细致的过程。到处都是各种中世纪风格的工具和细小的木屑。
Oboists are the most optimistic people in the world. Because every time they make a reed, they think that it might work. They usually don't, but anyway.
双簧管演奏家是世界上最乐观的人。因为每次他们做哨片，都以为它可能会成功。通常都不会，但无论如何。
This part, I-- oh, no, I'm skipping the most important part. You need to pick your color of thread. And it just makes all the difference, and I never know what color to pick. But this is the only fun that I have, so.
这一部分，我——噢，不，我跳过了最重要的一部分。你需要选择你的线颜色。这完全不一样，我从来不知道该选什么颜色。但这是我唯一的乐趣，所以。
[BLOWING ON REED]
[吹哨片]
That god-awful noise.
那种可怕的声音。
Melanie studied at Juilliard. She dreamed of being the principal oboist in the Metropolitan Opera or the Philharmonic. But she kept bombing her auditions. Her nerves got the best of her every time she was up for a big seat.
梅兰妮在朱莉亚音乐学院学习过。她梦想成为大都会歌剧院或爱乐乐团的首席双簧管。但她一直面试失败。每次去争夺重要的席位，紧张感都会击垮她。
And then, life and bills intervened. Phantom, in that way, is a very good job, in a field where there aren't a lot of good jobs anymore. It put Melanie's kids through college, paid her mortgage, and provided security while the music industry collapsed around her.
然后，生活和账单介入了。在那方面，《魅影》是一份非常好的工作，在一个已经没有多少好工作的领域。它让梅兰妮的孩子们上了大学，付清了她的抵押贷款，并在音乐产业在她周围崩溃时提供了保障。
But at the end of 30 years sitting just inches away from your coworkers, you lose all sense of proportion. Your enemies turn into monsters. For Melanie, the monster in the pit was always a trumpet player named Francis Bonny. Everything he did drove Melanie nuts, from the black biking shorts he wore in the pit, to always eating his dinner in the locker room with his back turned to her.
但在坐在距离同事仅几英寸的地方30年后，你失去了所有的比例感。你的敌人变成了怪物。对梅兰妮来说，乐池里的怪物一直是一个叫弗朗西斯·邦尼的小号手。他所做的一切都让梅兰妮抓狂，从他在乐池里穿的黑色骑行短裤，到总是在更衣室背对着她吃晚饭。
Francis was a miserable son of a bitch. And at a certain point, he started wearing-- like, he put this black shade on the side of his glasses. And he's wearing those things because he doesn't want to see me, right? That's why he's wear-- I really, truly believe this.
弗朗西斯是个悲惨的混蛋。在某个时候，他开始戴——就像，他在眼镜侧面戴上了这个黑色遮光板。他戴着那些东西是因为他不想看见我，对吧？这就是他为什么要戴——我真的，真正地相信这一点。
I wanted to run this all by Francis. It just seems so unreasonable. Francis is the only person I had talked to who had actually escaped from the pit. He got in a truck and drove out to the middle of nowhere in Colorado. He says he's much happier now.
我想把这一切都告诉弗朗西斯。这看起来太不合理了。弗朗西斯是我谈过的唯一一个真正从乐池里逃出来的人。他开着一辆卡车驶向科罗拉多州人迹罕至的地方。他说他现在快乐多了。
You spoke with Melanie! Oh!
你和梅兰妮谈过了！噢！
(LAUGHING) Yeah, yeah, we did. I understand that you two did not have the best relationship. One of the things that she told us was that you basically made an eye patch, so that you wouldn't have to look at her. Is this a true story that she's telling us?
（大笑）是的，是的，我们谈过了。据我了解你们俩的关系不太好。她告诉我们的一件事是，你基本做了一个眼罩，这样你就不用看她了。她告诉我们的这个故事是真的吗？
I did do that at some point. But that wasn't just because of Melanie. She's taking it too personally. It was actually anybody that was on my right.
我确实在某个时候那么做过。但这不仅仅是因为梅兰妮。她太把它当个人恩怨了。其实是对我右边的任何人都一样。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
She told us, for a long time, that you sat in the locker room, and that you would turn your back to everybody, because you didn't want to look at them.
她告诉我们，很长一段时间里，你坐在更衣室里，总是背对着所有人，因为你不想看他们。
Yeah, yeah, it was in the locker room. I came there, I ate my dinner, looked at the white wall, went in, played the show, and then left the theater, left the premises as fast as I could. And it worked beautifully.
是的，是的，那是在更衣室里。我到了那儿，吃了晚饭，看着白墙，进去，演完戏，然后尽可能快地离开剧院，离开现场。这效果非常好。
Can you compare the relationships that you have with other relationships?
你能把你拥有的那些关系与其他关系做比较吗？
It's family. [LAUGHS] It's your spouse you can't stand. And putting up with people that you just don't want to hear their voice again. You sit there. Thousands and thousands and thousands and thousands of hours. This is like a quarter of a lifetime.
这是家庭。[笑] 这是你无法忍受的配偶。还要忍受你再也不想听到他们声音的人。你就坐在那里。成千上万个小时。这就像一生的四分之一。
The musicians in the pit don't play the whole time, which means there are thousands of hours where they're not actually doing anything. And during those rests, they read books-- spy thrillers and mysteries-- and do the crossword with their neighbors.
乐池里的音乐家们并没有一直在演奏，这意味着有成千上万个小时他们实际上什么也没做。在休息期间，他们读书——间谍小说和神秘小说——并和邻座一起做填字游戏。
A trumpet player has taught himself three languages. Another musician ran a woodshop business on his laptop during the show. And socially, it's a bit like middle school. There are the loners, the jocks, and the French horns. They're like the boys in the back of the bus.
一位小号手自学了三种语言。另一位音乐家在演出期间用笔记本电脑经营着一家木工企业。在社交方面，它有点像初中。有独行侠、运动健将和法国号手。他们就像坐在车后座的男孩。
They bring in fart machines and run the same practical jokes over and over. Sometimes they even mess with the audience. The front row is right up against the pit, so close that their feet sometimes dangle next to the musicians' heads. Occasionally, one of the French horn players would take out a bottle of Wite-Out and write little messages on the soles of the audience's shoes.
他们带进屁垫，一遍又一遍地开同样的恶作剧。有时他们甚至会捉弄观众。前排离乐池很近，近到他们的脚有时会悬在音乐家的头旁边。偶尔，其中一位法国号手会拿出一瓶涂改液，在观众鞋底写下小信息。
Those guys-- they're sitting right behind me-- they're always chattering and laughing. I, being me, if I play badly, I think, oh, god, they're saying how terrible I am. Oh, god, I don't want to humiliate myself.
那些家伙——他们就坐在我后面——他们总是叽叽喳喳地笑个不停。像我这样的人，如果我演奏得不好，我想，天哪，他们肯定在说我有多糟糕。天哪，我不想羞辱自己。
This, more than anything, Melanie told me, is what makes her want to sound good every night. She's worried the French horn guys will make fun of her.
梅兰妮告诉我，这比什么都更能让她想每晚都演奏得好。她担心那些法国号手会取笑她。
I'm not playing for the audience, because the audience doesn't know. And so I'm playing for those French horn players. I do want to say, one of the compliments I've gotten over the years is, how do you still play so well when you've just been doing Phantom for all those years? I say, it's a choice that I've made. My choice is to play this music like it's any other music that I play, and make it beautiful.
我不是为了观众演奏的，因为观众不知道。所以我是在为那些法国号手演奏。我想说，这些年来我得到过的一个赞美是，你是怎么在做了这么多年的《魅影》后依然演奏得这么好的？我说，这是我做出的选择。我的选择是像对待我演奏的其他任何音乐一样对待这些音乐，并让它变得优美。
Can you just play something from Phantom?
你能随便演奏一段《魅影》吗？
Well, I can play the really hard ones. If it's really bad, though, I beg you not to--
好吧，我可以演奏那些非常难的片段。但如果是真的很糟糕的话，我请求你别——
[PLAYING OBOE]
[演奏双簧管]
During the pandemic, like the rest of Broadway, Phantom shut down. The unstoppable show was put on pause for a year and a half. I checked in with Melanie during that break. She wasn't doing very well. She wasn't getting paid by the show.
在疫情期间，和百老汇的其他剧目一样，《魅影》停演了。这部不可阻挡的剧目被暂停了一年半。在那段间隙我探访了梅兰妮。她过得并不好。她没从剧里拿到薪水。
And she missed Phantom. This was surprising to me. Melanie and all the other musicians had told me about their fantasies of finally leaving the show, and I had believed them. But now that it actually happened, she missed the routine.
而且她想念《魅影》。这让我很惊讶。梅兰妮和其他音乐家都告诉过我他们最终离开这个剧组的幻想，我也相信了他们。但现在真正发生了，她想念那种常规。
You know, Phantom-- I miss the comradeship, the repetition of the silly jokes, and watching everyone eat. And I don't know. The routine-- I kind of like routine in my life.
你知道，《魅影》——我想念这种战友情谊，愚蠢笑话的重复，还有看着大家吃东西。我不知道。这种常规——我其实喜欢我生活中的常规。
This, of course, is the opposite of what she'd said in the past, before COVID.
这当然与她新冠疫情前所说的恰恰相反。
It was always easy to complain that it was boring and to complain about driving into the city and wasting all that time in the car, and playing the same music, and going home again. And I just thought-- I knew I was lucky back then, but it becomes very real now. I mean, what can I say? Now, I really know what it's like not having this job.
抱怨它枯燥乏味，抱怨开车进城，浪费那么多时间在车里，演奏同样的音乐，然后又回家，总是很容易。我当时心想——我知道我当时很幸运，但现在它变得非常真实。我的意思是，我能说什么呢？现在，我真的知道没有这份工作是什么感觉了。
It's just so much fun to complain about things that don't matter. Oh, the women in the bathroom, they're just always talking about their expensive hair and makeup. And I miss the women in the bathroom. And yeah, I'd be happy to complain about that again.
抱怨那些无关紧要的事情真是太有趣了。噢，洗手间里的女士们，她们总是谈论她们昂贵的头发和化妆品。我想念洗手间里的女士们。是的，我很乐意再次为此抱怨。
Before the pandemic, every time I talked to Melanie, I would ask how she was doing. Her answer always depended on parking. It's hard to park in Midtown, Manhattan. A good parking spot was a good day. A bad parking spot was a bad day. This is how she made sense of her life.
疫情前，每次我与梅兰妮交谈，我都会问她过得怎么样。她的回答总是取决于停车位。在曼哈顿中城停车很难。一个好的停车位就是美好的一天。一个糟糕的停车位就是糟糕的一天。这就是她理解生活的方式。
I think about this all the time. Most of our lives are spent finding parking for the job we don't want to do. Melanie's not alone in that. And after any number of years, those routines accumulate, and that's more or less your life.
我一直都在想这个。我们一生中大部分时间都花在为我们不想做的工作寻找停车位上。梅兰妮并不是唯一一个这样的人。经过若干年后，这些常规累积起来，这差不多就是你的一生。
Of all the people I talked to in the pit, one musician dealt with the mundane and inevitable repetition of life in a way that really stuck with me. For the past two decades in the pit, Kurt, the musician who described himself as a violin operator, has been dreaming up the most elaborate and metaphorically perfect coping mechanism. It's a band made up entirely of automatons. I met these robot musicians in a warehouse in Yonkers.
在我谈过的所有乐池音乐家里，有一位音乐家处理生活平庸和必然重复的方式让我印象深刻。过去二十年里，把自己形容为“小提琴操作员”的库尔特一直构思着最精妙且隐喻完美的应对机制。那是一支完全由自动装置组成的乐队。我在扬克斯的一个仓库里见到了这些机器人音乐家。
The PAM Band.
PAM乐队。
The PAM Band stands for Partially Artificial Musicians. Kurt's automatons are made up of scraps of metal and string, all wired up to a soundboard that Kurt can program to create whatever sounds he wants. There's Magnus, an electric chord organ, Krieg, the bass guitar, and then there's Rosie, the theremin.
PAM乐队代表“部分人工音乐家”。库尔特的自动装置由金属碎片和绳子组成，都连接到一个库尔特可以编程来创造他想要的任何声音的音板上。有马格努斯，一台电子和弦风琴，克里格，一把低音吉他，还有罗西，特雷门琴。
This is Jack, a solid-body electric violin using the exoskeleton design. This is what helps alleviate the boredom of the redundancy of Phantom. Because I'm constantly thinking about this project and how I can improve the automation and the kind of music that I would like to create.
这是杰克，一把使用外骨骼设计、实心体的电小提琴。这就是有助于缓解《魅影》冗余带来的无聊感的东西。因为我一直在思考这个项目以及我如何改进自动化，以及我想创造什么样的音乐。
Why did you decide to do this?
你为什么决定做这个？
If I ever see a therapist, maybe they will help me understand that.
如果我有机会看治疗师，也许他们能帮我理解这一点。
Let's pretend I'm a therapist.
假装我是治疗师。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Like, was there part of it where you're like, man, I am playing in this orchestra, I'm not-- it's not the expressiveness that I want, I also kind of feel like an automaton? You know? And maybe I just make an automaton as a violinist.
比如，有没有一部分是你觉得，天哪，我在这个乐团演奏，这——这并没有我想要的表现力，而且我感觉自己也像个自动装置？你知道吗？也许我只是做一个自动装置作为小提琴手。
Sure, yeah. I mean, I can see exploring that-- am I looking for some kind of soul healing from this dehumanization of being in a violin section? Possibly. [CHUCKLES]
当然，是的。我的意思是，我能明白去探索这个——我是否在寻求某种灵魂治愈，以摆脱在小提琴组里的这种非人化？可能吧。[轻笑]
I asked Kurt if the PAM Band could play "The Music of the Night," or "All I Ask of You," or any of the Phantom classics. He wasn't into that, at all. This band was not designed to play Andrew Lloyd Webber.
我问库尔特，PAM乐队能不能演奏《夜之音乐》，或者《我所要求的一切》，或者任何经典的《魅影》片段。他一点也不感兴趣。这支乐队根本不是为了演奏安德鲁·劳埃德·韦伯而设计的。
But something inside him just couldn't get away from Phantom of the Opera. Back when he was sitting in the pit, he'd composed, just in his head, both the prequel and the sequel to Phantom, both which involve Indiana Jones-type characters.
但他内心的某些东西就是无法逃离《歌剧魅影》。当他坐在乐池里时，他已经在脑子里构思了《魅影》的前传和续集，都涉及印第安纳·琼斯类型的角色。
And years ago, he got a copy of the 1925 silent film version of Phantom and wrote an entire score. He wanted to play it for me. He turned off the lights in the warehouse and projected the film onto the wall. The PAM Band started to play.
几年前，他买了一份1925年无声电影版的《魅影》，并写了整部配乐。他想把它演给我看。他关掉仓库里的灯，把电影投射到墙上。PAM乐队开始演奏。
The score features him, Kurt, as a solo violinist and the star of the show. The automatons all play the same thing, but Kurt always improvises. None of his shows are ever the same.
配乐以他，库尔特，作为独奏小提琴手和明星为特色。自动装置都演奏同样的东西，但库尔特总是即兴发挥。他的表演从不重复。
Jay Caspian Kang is a staff writer for The New Yorker and co-host of the podcast, Time to Say Goodbye. His story was produced by Miki Meek.
杰伊·卡斯皮安·康是《纽约客》的特约撰稿人，也是播客《再见时刻》的联合主持人。他的故事由米基·米克制作。
So we first broadcast that story three years ago. And now, the decades of repetition in the Phantom of the Opera pit are finally coming to an end. After 35 years, the longest-running show in Broadway history is closing this week. Curious how the musicians in the pit were taking the news, Jay caught up with Melanie, the oboe player, when she just had four shows left to play. Jay asked about the moment when everybody who works on the show heard definitively, during a big Zoom meeting, actually, that the show was finally closing.
我们在三年前首次播出了那个故事。现在，《歌剧魅影》乐池里几十年的重复终于要结束了。在35年之后，百老汇历史上演出时间最长的剧目将于本周落幕。好奇乐池里的音乐家们如何看待这个消息，杰伊在梅兰妮仅剩四场演出时赶上了她。杰伊询问了当剧组所有工作人员在一次大型Zoom会议上最终确认演出真的要结束时的那一刻。
What was your first thought? Because I remember that we had talked about it, and you sort of-- you and Lowell and Pete had all sort of fantasized about it. Because I asked you about this a lot, just like, well, what are you going to-- like, when you leave, how is it going to feel?
你的第一个想法是什么？因为我记得我们讨论过，而且你和洛厄尔、皮特都对此充满了幻想。因为我经常问你这个问题，比如，好吧，你要——比如，当你离开时，会是什么感觉？
Right.
没错。
And so like, how did it actually feel? Like, 'cause you finally got confirmation that, OK, this is actually going to end.
所以最终感觉如何？因为你终于得到了证实，好吧，这一切真的要结束了。
So the first thing is the dropping-of-your-gut-into-the-cellar kind of feeling, of shock, just complete shock. Like the-bottom-is-falling-out-of-my-world kind of feeling. I was upset.
第一件事就是那种让你心沉入地窖的感觉，震惊，完全的震惊。那种世界底层崩塌的感觉。我当时很难过。
So what I do-- I said, I don't want to be sad, so I will be angry. Let's choose anger. And I said, I'm going to focus on all the things I hate. And that way, I won't be sad. And so that's what I did.
所以我做了什么——我说，我不想难过，所以我选择生气。让我们选择愤怒。我说，我要专注于所有我讨厌的事情。那样，我就不会难过了。所以我就是这么做的。
Well, did it work? Like, did it work to--
嗯，奏效了吗？比如，奏效了吗——
Yeah, I was so successful.
是的，我非常成功。
--to just focus on everything you hate, instead of whatever feelings of sadness or regret or even fear that might have popped up?
——专注于你讨厌的一切，而不是任何可能冒出来的悲伤、遗憾甚至恐惧的情绪？
No, this is at the beginning. OK, so, I was so good, right? I was so successful. Now that it's imminent, I do feel different. So now, it's much more of a rollercoaster up and down. Right now, there's all kinds of exciting activities going on.
不，那是在刚开始的时候。好吧，所以，我很擅长，对吧？我非常成功。现在它迫在眉睫，我的感觉确实不同了。所以现在，这更像是一个起起伏伏的过山车。现在，有各种各样的兴奋活动正在进行。
And then, you can sort of forget that it's closing. I am certainly sad about it. It's an entire way of life. I can't even really imagine knowing it will never be back. But most of those people, I'm never going to see again.
然后，你有时会忘记它要结束了。我当然对此感到难过。这是一种完整的生活方式。我甚至无法想象知道它永远不会回来了。但其中大部分人，我永远不会再见到他们了。
Are people being nicer to one another in the pit?
人们在乐池里对彼此更好了吗？
Thank you for asking. [LAUGHS] People are being so nice. I'm trying to be quieter about things that annoy me, but fewer things are annoying me. And it's all very festive and fun.
谢谢你这么问。[笑] 大家现在都很友善。我尽量对那些让我恼火的事情保持安静，但确实让我恼火的事情变少了。这看起来很喜庆很有趣。
We had a really fun photo op on Friday. They had a full company photo call, so. I really enjoyed it, because everybody was up on stage. They all gave us a poster, and everyone's getting their posters signed like your high school yearbook.
周五我们拍了一张非常开心的照片。他们进行了一次全员拍照，所以。我真的很喜欢，因为每个人都在舞台上。他们给了我们每个人一张海报，每个人都在签名，就像你们高中的毕业纪念册一样。
You know, when I first interviewed you several years ago, one of the things that you told me that made me laugh a lot was that you, after playing 20-something years at the time of the show, had never actually seen the show. And that sort of blew my mind, because I was like, how do you go every night? Like, you've never actually seen the show?
你知道，当几年前我第一次采访你时，你告诉我的让我大笑的一件事是，在演奏了二十多年之后，你其实从来没看过这部剧。这让我感到震惊，因为我心想，你是怎么每晚都去的？你从来没看过这部剧？
Yeah. So I realized that I really wanted to see the show, and I asked the management, and they set me up at the soundboard. And it was wonderful. This is just last week, I think.
是的。所以我意识到我真的很想看这部剧，我请求管理层，他们把我安排在控制室。这太棒了。我想这就在上周。
And what amazed me was the pageantry of it, the beauty of it. I had no idea. You see them bringing in all the ice backstage, outside of the stage door, every day. So there's a giant ice container, the dry ice, and then they carry it in.
让我感到惊讶的是它的宏大和美丽。我根本不知道。你每天看到他们在后台、舞台门外搬进所有的冰块。所以有一个巨大的冰容器，干冰，然后他们把它搬进去。
And then, we used to complain about the smoke. But I never knew what the smoke did. And so it creates this incredible atmosphere, and then there's all these lights. Like, we see the candelabra under the stage, but they're not lit under the stage.
以前我们总是抱怨烟雾。但我从来不知道烟雾是做什么用的。它创造了一种不可思议的氛围，然后还有所有的灯光。比如，我们在舞台下看到了烛台，但它们在舞台下并没有被点亮。
And so I got to see them on the stage. And I got to see the Phantom and Christine at the end of-- I don't know which number it was, but they just disappear. I mean, it's a trapdoor, but you have this effect that they're just disappearing. And I feel like a little kid, in a way-- just awestruck by all these things that other people have seen so many times.
所以我在舞台上看到了它们。我在最后看到魅影和克里斯汀——我不知道是哪一段，但他们只是消失了。我的意思是，那是一个活板门，但你有一种他们只是消失了的效果。我觉得自己像个孩子——被其他人看过这么多次的所有这些东西所震撼。
11 people who are going to be in the pit closing night are musicians who were there on opening night, back in 1988. I was able to reach Lowell Hershey, who, as Jay pointed out in the story, everybody calls the sanest person in the pit. Like Melanie, Lowell has other gigs lined up for after Phantom closes, here and there. Nothing big, nothing too challenging.
闭幕之夜将在乐池里的11人是1988年首演之夜就在那里的音乐家。我联系到了洛厄尔·赫尔希，正如杰伊在故事中指出的，大家都称他为乐池里最清醒的人。和梅兰妮一样，洛厄尔在《魅影》结束后也排了其他演出。没什么大的，没什么太具挑战性的。
Neither of them imagines playing for another Broadway show, either as a sub or as a regular player. Lowell, I have to say, was very chill about the closing.
他们俩谁也没想过去为另一部百老汇剧目演奏，无论是作为替补还是正式成员。不得不说，洛厄尔对闭幕非常淡定。
You know, I can't say that I didn't enjoy going to work. I did. It's fun for me to do that, and so I will miss that. But you know, I think I can find other things that will interest me. I don't feel like I'll be bored.
你知道，我不能说我不享受这份工作。我确实享受。对我来说这很有趣，所以我会想念它。但你知道，我想我可以找到其他能引起我兴趣的事情。我觉得我不会感到无聊。
How old were you on the first opening night?
第一次首演之夜你多大？
I was 40.
我40岁。
Can I ask you to go back and imagine, for a second, 40-year-old you on the opening night of Phantom? If you could somehow have said to him, you will be here for 35 years, and you'll be here on closing night of this show, what would that 40-year-old have said?
我能请你回去想象一下，哪怕一秒钟，40岁的你在《魅影》的首演之夜吗？如果你能不知何故对他说，你会在这里待上35年，而且你会在这里迎接这部剧的闭幕之夜，那个40岁的你会说什么？
Well, I would have been really happy to have heard that. Because at the time Phantom opened, I had an 11- and a 13-year-old-- two kids, and college was coming up. And if you told me that Phantom was going to go more than just a few years, and go 35, I would have been thrilled, because that would have meant that I would have some security. So yeah, I would have been very happy to have that information.
嗯，听到这个我会非常高兴。因为在《魅影》首演时，我有两个孩子，一个11岁，一个13岁——大学快要到了。如果你告诉我《魅影》不仅仅运行几年，而是持续35年，我会欣喜若狂，因为那意味着我会有一些保障。所以是的，得到那个信息我会非常高兴。
Coming up-- a mom goes underground, goes undercover, to get an urgent message to her daughter. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来——一位母亲深入地下，秘密行动，为女儿传递一条紧急信息。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program-- "What Lies Beneath," the stories of things and people, usually hidden from view, coming to the surface. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, "How I Met My Mother."
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——“隐藏在表面之下”，关于那些通常隐藏在视线之外的事物和人的故事，浮出水面。我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“我是如何遇见我母亲的”。
So in some families, what's buried deep below are the true feelings that people have about one another. There's so many people out there who have trouble saying directly what they really feel. One of the producers here at our show, Elna Baker, comes from a long line of passive-aggressive communicators.
所以在一些家庭中，深埋地下的是人们彼此之间真实的感受。有很多人难以直接说出他们真实的感受。我们节目的一位制作人艾尔娜·贝克来自一个被动攻击型交流者的大家族。
By the way, they know this. They own it. When her grandmother wanted to get a message across, a message like, don't leave change lying around, one time, she put an article on the fridge saying, "Toddler Chokes on Penny," and then just left it to everybody else to connect the dots.
顺便说一句，他们知道这一点。他们承认。当她的祖母想要传达一个信息，比如，“别让硬币乱放”，有一次，她贴了一篇关于“幼儿被硬币噎住”的文章在冰箱上，然后就把这件事留给其他人去联系上下文了。
Elna's mother communicates in the same indirect way, which became a problem in the years after Elna left the church. Elna's family's Mormon, and her mom had some important things that she wanted to say to her. Here's Elna.
艾尔娜的母亲以同样间接的方式进行交流，这在艾尔娜离开教会后的几年里成了一个问题。艾尔娜的家庭是摩门教徒，她妈妈有些重要的话想对她说。这是艾尔娜。
This all started when I made a joke about me buying weed to my brother. Careful, he said. If Mom were to hear that, she'd send an email to the whole family about how you're an addict. I laughed. And then, I was like, wait, what? That was way too specific.
这一切始于我对我哥哥开了一个关于我买大麻的玩笑。他说，小心点。如果妈妈听到了，她会给全家发一封电子邮件，说你是个瘾君子。我笑了。然后我想，等等，什么？这太具体了。
Did Mom send an email to the whole family about me being an addict? And he was like, uh, mm, nothing, never mind, which could only mean one thing. She did. It took several rounds of questioning before I got the whole story.
妈妈给全家发了关于我是瘾君子的邮件吗？他说，呃，嗯，没什么，别介意，这只能意味着一件事。她确实发了。经过几轮询问，我才弄清了整个故事。
The email he was referencing-- my mom had sent it 10 years ago. At the time, I was about to host a comedy show in New York, where me and a bunch of performers would play drinking games on stage. It was called The Drunk Show.
他提到的邮件——我妈妈是10年前发的。当时，我正要主持一场喜剧秀，我和一群表演者会在舞台上玩酒令。它叫“醉酒秀”。
The show was being promoted online. My mom, a devout Mormon, saw an article about it and freaked out. Mormons don't drink. It's against the religion.
该节目正在网上进行推广。我虔诚的摩门教徒母亲看到一篇相关文章后吓坏了。摩门教徒不喝酒。这违反宗教信仰。
And what I learned from my brother, years after the fact, is that my mom was so worried that I was doing this show, she sent an email to my family, my extended family, uncles, cousins, and family friends who I grew up with, like the Mitchells, the Coxes-- Heidi, my middle school drama teacher.
我从我哥哥那里了解到，事后多年，我妈妈非常担心我做这个节目，她给我的家人、我的大家庭、叔叔、堂兄弟姐妹以及和我一起长大的家庭朋友发了电子邮件，比如米切尔一家、考克斯一家——海蒂，我初中的戏剧老师。
"Dear friends," it begins. "I am writing, because I am concerned about the direction Elna's life has turned. She is spiraling downward, fast."
“亲爱的朋友们，”邮件开头写道。“我写信是因为我担心艾尔娜的生活方向。她正在迅速陷入深渊。”
My mom then explains to them that I'm doing this event called, The Drunk Show, then writes, "I am very concerned. In our family, you are either an alcoholic or a Mormon. And I think she may be headed in the wrong direction. I don't know what I can do personally. She doesn't hear me."
我妈妈向他们解释我在做一个叫“醉酒秀”的活动，然后写道，“我非常担心。在我们家，你要么是酒鬼，要么是摩门教徒。我觉得她可能走错了方向。我不知道我个人能做什么。她不听我的。”
I'm going to interject here-- that I didn't hear her, because she never said anything to me about it. In the email, she inserts a link to the article about The Drunk Show, and then reveals her grand master plan. She's been commenting on the article, under fake names, warning me not to do the show.
我在这里插一句——我没听她的，是因为她从来没跟我提过这件事。在邮件里，她附上了关于“醉酒秀”的文章链接，然后揭露了她宏伟的大计划。她一直用假名在文章下留言，警告我不要做这个节目。
"Can everyone else please make up fake accounts and also comment? This way, I'll cancel the show." She ends, "Thanks. Pray for us both, please."
“其他人能注册假账户并评论吗？这样，我就能取消这个节目了。”她结尾写道，“谢谢。请为我们俩祈祷。”
When I read this email, I was mortified. I drink socially. I'm not an alcoholic. But since I'd never intercepted the email, I worried everyone who got it had thought this for years. I immediately clicked on the link to the article.
读这封邮件时，我感到既尴尬又羞愧。我只是社交场合喝酒。我不是酒鬼。但因为我从没截获过这封邮件，我担心所有收到它的人多年来都这么认为。我立刻点击了文章链接。
At the bottom of the page, there were four comments from four different people, trolling me, all clearly my mother. Her first fake character is Carol from the West Village, who says, quote, "Encouraging irresponsible drinking that could end in hospitalization of performers is an invitation to a lawsuit. Don't be idiots."
页面底部有四个人留下的四条评论，在戏弄我，很明显都是我妈妈。她的第一个假角色是来自西村的卡罗尔，她说，引述，“鼓励可能导致表演者住院的不负责任饮酒是起诉的邀请。别当傻子。”
The three other comments escalate from there. Here's the weirdest part. She wrote all these comments while she was staying with me. She was in town the week of The Drunk Show. We slept in the same bed. But she didn't say a word to me about it.
其他三条评论从那开始升级。最奇怪的部分是。她写这些评论的时候正和我待在一起。“醉酒秀”那一周她在城里。我们睡在同一张床上。但她没对我提过一个字。
As interventions go, it was the least successful one I've ever heard of or could imagine. No one else among the family or friends chimed in. And I, the target of the intervention, never knew it happened. I never heard of or read the comments online until my brother accidentally let it slip, years later.
谈到干预，这是我所听过或能想象到的最不成功的一次。家人或朋友中没有其他人应声。而我，干预的目标，从未知道发生了什么。直到几年后我哥哥不小心说漏嘴，我才在网上看到或读到这些评论。
Since I found out about this, I've wondered why my mom chose to communicate this message to me the way she did. But I've never asked her, because I figured it would just lead to a fight and no answers. But we're much closer now than we were when I did The Drunk Show. Why not try?
自从我知道这件事后，我一直想知道为什么我妈妈选择用那种方式向我传达这个信息。但我从未问过她，因为我想那只会导致争吵而没有答案。但我们现在比我做“醉酒秀”的时候亲近多了。为什么不试试呢？
To my surprise, she agreed to talk about it, but on these conditions. Dad had to be there, in case we needed mediation. I had to come home for Christmas in exchange. And most importantly, I could only do this story if she got to write the ending, which we'll get to later.
令我惊讶的是，她同意谈谈，但有条件。爸爸必须在场，以防我们需要调解。我得回家过圣诞节作为交换。最重要的是，我只有在她能写结尾的情况下才能做这个故事，我们稍后会讲到。
Talk for a second?
谈一会儿？
Hi, Elna. How are you?
你好，艾尔娜。你好吗？
Wow, Mom, you got sexy.
哇，妈妈，你变性感了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Wow, Mom.
哇，妈妈。
I'm trying out a lower voice, because I think my voice is too screechy.
我在尝试压低声音，因为我觉得我的声音太刺耳了。
Don't do that. (LAUGHING) Don't spend the whole interview not being yourself.
别那样。（大笑）别花整场采访时间不去做你自己。
We started at the beginning. How did my mother decide that anonymous comments online would be the best way to reach me? She said my sister, Julia, told her about The Drunk Show.
我们从头开始。我母亲是如何认定网上的匿名评论是联系我的最好方式的？她说我姐姐朱莉娅告诉了她关于“醉酒秀”的事。
So I'm laying there on the couch. I'm at your apartment, probably about 5:00 in the morning. And I'm stewing over this. I can't sleep. I haven't slept for hours.
所以我躺在沙发上。我在你的公寓里，可能大约凌晨5点。我正在为这件事心烦意乱。我睡不着。我已经好几个小时没睡了。
And then, I just had this little epiphany. I can put this on here in somebody else's voice. I don't have to use my own voice. And then, maybe she'll take it seriously. You just need to hear it from New Yorkers.
然后，我突然有了小小的顿悟。我可以把这个用别人的声音放在这里。我不必使用我自己的声音。然后，也许她会认真对待。你只需要从纽约人那里听到它。
Why?
为什么？
Oh, come on, Elna. You're from New York, you live in New York, and you value their opinions.
噢，得了吧，艾尔娜。你是纽约人，你住在纽约，你重视他们的意见。
More than yours?
比你的还重要？
Oh, absolutely. Because I'm this fuddy-duddy, old-fashioned Mormon lady that doesn't know anything. You know? I'm, like, from 1950. I'm like June Cleaver.
噢，当然。因为我是个什么都不懂的、老派的摩门教老太太。你知道吗？我就像1950年的产物。我就像琼·克里弗。
Are you saying that you are like that, or that I think-- you think I think that?
你是说你就是那样，还是说我以为——你以为我以为你是那样？
That's what I think you think I am, yeah.
这就是我以为你认为我是那样的，没错。
Before things get too tense, my mom and I pull up the comments page together.
在情况变得太紧张之前，我妈妈和我一起打开了评论页面。
So now, let's look at these--
所以现在，让我们看看这些——
The first thing I learned was how fleshed out these people were in my mom's mind. Like, Carol from the West Village, who warned that irresponsible drinking could lead to lawsuits--
我学到的第一件事就是这些人在我妈心里有多丰满。比如，那个警告不负责任饮酒可能导致诉讼的来自西村的卡罗尔——
She's a lawyer. Because that's the way a lawyer would say things, isn't it?
她是名律师。因为这就是律师会说话的方式，不是吗？
OK.
好的。
She's dealt with lawsuits that have involved drunk drivers or something with alcohol involved, right?
她处理过涉及酒驾或涉及酒精的事情的诉讼，对吧？
To be clear, nowhere in the comments does it say Carol is a lawyer. For each entry, there's just a name and location, like Don from the Upper West Side.
需要明确的是，评论里没说卡罗尔是律师。每个条目只有名字和地点，比如来自上西区的唐。
Pretty ritzy area, right?
相当时髦的地区，对吧？
Mm. Who is Don in your mind?
嗯。在你的心目中唐是谁？
Don is a comedian--
唐是个喜剧演员——
Oh. OK.
噢。好的。
--who's older. He used to do, kind of, the old-style comedy.
——年纪比较大。他过去做的是，那种老派的喜剧。
Again, reading the comments, you'd never know Don was a comedian.
再说一次，读这些评论，你永远不会知道唐是个喜剧演员。
Yeah, he's just disgusted with how comedy has evolved in the last 15 years or so.
是的，他只是对喜剧在过去15年左右的发展方式感到厌恶。
What does Don think about me doing this show?
唐怎么看待我做这个节目？
He says, "Comedy, where you're laughing at the performers and not with the performers, is not comedy. It is tragedy. Is this really what NYC comedy is reduced to? Are you really not cleverer than this?"
他说，“喜剧，如果你是在嘲笑表演者而不是和表演者一起笑，那不是喜剧。那是悲剧。纽约喜剧真的降级到这种程度了吗？你真的不比这更聪明吗？”
Why did you think, like, Don saying this to me would reach me?
你为什么认为，比如，唐对我说这些话能触动我？
Well, you love comedians. I mean, it's all about the comedy for you.
好吧，你喜欢喜剧演员。我的意思是，这一切对你来说都是关于喜剧。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
So of course, if this is not going to be funny, then maybe we shouldn't do this.
所以当然，如果这不是好笑的，那么也许我们不该做这个。
The next comment comes from the East Village, from a commenter named, Please.
下一条评论来自东村，来自一位叫“请”（Please）的评论者。
OK, so I'm thinking this is a policeman.
好的，所以我想这是位警察。
And his name is Please?
而他的名字叫“请”？
Yeah, Officer Please.
是的，请警官。
It doesn't say, "Officer," Mom. (LAUGHING) It just says, "Please."
没写“警官”，妈妈。（大笑）它只写了，“请”。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
What-- why is this policeman writing me? Why is he so offended by this show?
为什么——为什么这位警察在给我写信？他为什么对这个节目这么反感？
Well, he says, "10 years after 9/11, and this is where New York is? Come on."
好吧，他说，“9/11过去10年了，这就是纽约现在的样子？得了吧。”
The show is on September 17.
该节目在9月17日。
"I think this week, of all weeks, we should all be a little more sensitive and full of introspection."
“我认为这周，在所有这些星期里，我们都应该更敏感，充满反思。”
OK. Um, can we just-- I think we can both agree that you went-- you went real big on this one.
好的。嗯，我们能——我想我们俩都能同意你在这上面做得太过火了。
I hit the 9/11 button.
我按下了9/11的按钮。
Her last comment is a straight-up Mormon talking point. Alcoholism and all other addictions take away freedom of choice. Seven minutes after she posted that, she sent the mass email. My mom said she went so hard because--
她的最后一条评论是一个直接的摩门教谈话要点。酗酒和其他成瘾行为会剥夺自由选择的权利。在她发布后七分钟，她发了那封群发邮件。我妈妈说她做得那么过火是因为——
So I have two uncles who died of alcoholism poisoning. My uncle died at age 30. My other uncle came to my wedding completely drunk and ended up dead about two years later, from alcoholism. Gary's grandfather died of alcoholism.
我有两位叔叔死于酒精中毒。我的叔叔30岁时去世。我的另一位叔叔在我的婚礼上烂醉如泥，大约两年后死于酗酒。加里的祖父死于酗酒。
So that's how I get there. It's not like it's a Mormon thing. It's an experience that has affected me. It affected my mother. She was just devastated over her brother and his alcoholism.
所以我就是这样得出的结论。这不像是一种摩门教的事。这是一种影响我的经历。它影响了我的母亲。她对自己哥哥和他的酗酒感到崩溃。
Stopping The Drunk Show meant stopping me from becoming one of these people. My mom says she saw the promo photo of me sipping a drink on the page announcing the show, and thought--
阻止“醉酒秀”意味着阻止我变成这些人中的一员。我妈妈说她看到我宣传照上啜饮饮料，宣布节目，并想——
Has she lost her mind? She has relatives who died of alcoholism. She's been taught since she was little girl to be careful around alcohol. Has she completely blocked out everything I've ever taught her?
她失去理智了吗？她有死于酗酒的亲戚。她从小就被教导在酒精面前要小心。她完全封锁了我教给她的所有事情吗？
Did you ever consider just calling me?
你有没有考虑过直接给我打电话？
Elna, we've already been there. You don't hear me! You just don't hear me. It's just a joke. You have to hear it from somebody who you think is credible.
艾尔娜，我们已经谈过那个了。你不听我的！你就是不听我的。这只是个玩笑。你得从你认为可信的人那里听到它。
Come on. Admit it, Elna. You know you would have just laughed. You would have called Kevin, you would have had a good laugh, and you would have had the show anyway.
得了吧。承认吧，艾尔娜。你知道你只会大笑。你会打电话给凯文，你会大笑一场，而且你还是会做那个节目。
But you didn't-- the thing--
但你没——那件事——
Come on, admit it.
得了吧，承认吧。
Wait.
等等。
You know it. You know you would have rolled your eyes at me.
你知道的。你知道你只会对我翻白眼。
But you didn't even try.
但你甚至没尝试。
But Elna, just-- just tell me. What's the truth on your end?
但艾尔娜，只是——只是告诉我。在你那边事实是什么？
Well, I don't think I-- here's the thing. I think if you just told me not to do it, I would have-- I would have done exactly what you're saying. But if we'd had a full conversation where we really talked-- like, so for example, I didn't know until just now, until we've had this conversation-- like, I didn't really know that much about your family history with drinking.
嗯，我不认为我——事情是这样的。我想如果你只是告诉我不要做它，我会——我会做你说的完全一样的事情。但如果我们进行了一次充分的交谈，我们真的谈过了——比如，所以我直到现在才知道，直到我们进行了这次对话——比如，我真的不太了解你家庭的饮酒历史。
You don't talk about these unpleasant things, so that when you're so against drinking, I think I did think it was just had to do with Mormonism, and not that it had to do with really painful things you witnessed in your life. Because you never told me about them.
你从不谈论这些令人不快的事情，所以当你如此反对饮酒时，我想我确实以为它只是和摩门教有关，而不是和你在生活中目睹的真正痛苦的事情有关。因为你从来没告诉过我它们。
I'm sure I've said this statement before in your life. In our family, you're either a Mormon or an--
我肯定我在你的生活中说过这句话。在我们家，你要么是摩门教徒，要么是——
Alcoholic.
酒鬼。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, you heard that one before.
是的，你以前听过那个。
Yeah, I just didn't believe it.
是的，我只是不相信。
She'd said this to me all my life, but I was missing the context. I've never met any of these family members who drank. I don't remember her ever mentioning any of these stories. I saw my mother as sheltered. Almost all her friends are Mormon. I just thought she doesn't know what she's talking about, which was unfair.
她一生都在对我这样说，但我缺少背景。我从未见过这些喝酒的家庭成员。我不记得她提过任何这些故事。我看到的母亲是受庇护的。她几乎所有的朋友都是摩门教徒。我只是认为她不知道自己在说什么，这不公平。
When I make a radio story, I listen to my interviews over and over again. And this time, something unusual started to happen. With each listen, my mother sounded less and less like my mother.
当我制作电台故事时，我会一遍又一遍地听我的采访。这一次，不寻常的事情发生了。随着每一次倾听，我母亲听起来越来越不像我的母亲。
Like, I stopped hearing her the way I usually do-- rolling my eyes, getting defensive. And I actually started to hear what she had to say. This is the line that struck me the hardest.
比如，我不再以我通常的方式听她说话——翻白眼，变得有防御性。我实际上开始听她在说什么。这是触动我最深的一句话。
Elna, we've already been there. You don't hear me.
艾尔娜，我们已经谈过那个了。你不听我的。
She's right. And I can hear in her voice that this has been hurting her feelings for years. And that's my fault. I see why she thinks it's hopeless to talk to me about drinking, about anything. I'm incredibly dismissive. That's my part in this.
她是正确的。我能听出她的声音里这种痛苦多年来一直伤害着她的感情。那是我的错。我明白为什么她认为跟我谈论饮酒、谈论任何事情都是徒劳的。我极其轻蔑。那是我的问题。
And her part-- she was totally upfront about that. She didn't want to confront me about drinking, because she has so much trouble with confrontation of any kind, with anyone, going back to when she was young.
而她的部分——她对此完全坦诚。她不想和我对抗饮酒，因为她对任何形式的对抗都有很大的困难，对任何人，追溯到她年轻的时候。
I mean, as a little kid, I used to just admit fault to anything that happened in our family in order to get the confrontation to be over with.
我的意思是，作为个小孩子，我过去常常承认我们家里发生的任何事情的错误，以便让对抗结束。
I never understood before this conversation what that feels like for her. She panics, feels trapped, like she needs to run, tightness in her chest, which is what makes this conversation so hard.
在这次谈话之前，我从未理解那对她来说是什么感觉。她会恐慌，感到被困，好像她需要跑，胸口发紧，这使得这次谈话如此艰难。
This is-- we're doing exactly what I hate to do.
这是——我们在做我最讨厌做的事情。
What?
什么？
Talk about conflict. [CHUCKLES]
谈论冲突。[轻笑]
So what's happening to you when we do it?
那么当我们做这件事时你发生了什么？
Well, let's see, I'm twiddling my thumbs, right? I'm feeling my neck turn to stone.
好吧，让我看看，我正在摆弄大拇指，对吧？我感觉到脖子变成了石头。
This cord, which is already coiled up, has been triple-coiled--
这根绳子，本来就卷在一起，现在被三倍卷起——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--for the headphones.
——为了耳机。
[CHUCKLES] So yeah.
[轻笑] 所以是的。
Well, thank you for putting yourself in your most uncomfortable place.
好吧，谢谢你把自己置于你最不舒服的地方。
Sure. You're welcome, Elna. Anything for my daughter.
当然。不客气，艾尔娜。为了我的女儿什么都行。
I knew what this meant. From the tone of her voice, it was time to stop. This was the most direct conversation I've ever had with my mother and the longest real conversation we've ever had. She'd gone above and beyond and did something she did not enjoy, for me. I could return the favor and call it a day.
我知道这意味着什么。从她的语调来看，是时候停止了。这是我和我母亲进行过的最直接的对话，也是我们进行过的最长的真实对话。她付出了超乎寻常的努力，做了一件她不喜欢的事情，为了我。我可以投桃报李，到此为止。
Well, folks, my ticket home for Christmas is booked. And now, for the ending my mother requested-- it comes down to three words-- "She was right." Not about me spiraling downward fast, but about The Drunk Show.
好了，伙计们，我的圣诞节回程票已经订好了。现在，为了我母亲要求的结尾——归结为三个词——“她是正确的。”不是关于我迅速陷入深渊，而是关于“醉酒秀”。
For the record, The Drunk Show was a disaster. I was the one who organized the drinking games, but because I'd only recently left the church, I was brand new to drinking. And all the penalties in the games were things like, take four shots of whiskey.
据我所知，“醉酒秀”是一场灾难。我是组织酒令的人，但因为我才刚离开教会不久，我对饮酒是新手。游戏中的所有惩罚都是诸如“喝四杯威士忌”之类的事情。
Things went off the rails quickly. A performer threw a chair at an audience member. I drunk-dialed my ex from the stage, and the call went so badly, that I started crying in front of the audience. Ira, who was in the show, got blackout drunk-- for the first time in his life, he said-- and then threw up into a trash bag.
事情很快就失控了。一位表演者向观众扔椅子。我在舞台上给我前任打了醉酒电话，电话打得太糟糕了，以至于我在观众面前开始哭。艾拉，当时在演出中，喝得酩酊大醉——他说这是他一生中第一次——然后吐进了垃圾袋。
And someone ended up in the hospital. My mom knew none of those details, of course. But big picture-- Carol from the West Village knew what she was talking about when she said irresponsible drinking can lead to hospitalization. In other words, Mom was right.
还有人进了医院。当然，我妈不知道那些细节。但总体来看——来自西村的卡罗尔在说不负责任的饮酒可能导致住院时，确实知道她在说什么。换句话说，妈妈是对的。
Elna Baker is one of the producers of our show and the author of the book, The New York Regional Mormon Singles Halloween Dance.
艾尔娜·贝克是我们节目的制作人之一，也是《纽约地区摩门教单身万圣节舞会》一书的作者。
["JUST UNDER THE SURFACE" BY VENICE]
["隐藏在表面之下" 威尼斯乐队]
Well, our program was produced today by Aviva DeKornfeld and Lina Misitzis. The people who put together today's rerun include Alaa Mostafa, Stowe Nelson, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
好吧，我们的节目今天由阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德和莉娜·米西齐斯制作。今天重播的制作人员包括阿拉·穆斯塔法、斯托·尼尔森、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。我们的主编是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Our website-- thisamericanlife.org, where you can hear over 700 episodes of our program for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费听到我们节目的700多集。本节目由公共广播交换平台PRX分发到公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He and I were talking the other day, and he let slip, he has not been listening to our program for weeks. Weeks! I was like, what? Totally confronted him about it. And I don't know. I guess he had a good reason.
像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。前几天我们谈话时，他随口说漏了嘴，他已经几周没听我们的节目了。几周！我心想，什么？完全因此质问他。我不确定。我想他有正当理由。
[SIGHS] I'm just so tired of the sound of your voice.
[叹气] 我真是太厌倦听你的声音了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week. I told Torey, I get it.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来。我告诉托里，我明白。
You know, and I'm tired of the sound of my voice, too, so I kind of sympathize.
你知道，我也厌倦听自己的声音了，所以我有点同情。
["JUST UNDER THE SURFACE" BY VENICE]
["隐藏在表面之下" 威尼斯乐队]